and if you could I would like you to ask
me questions about openings that affects
you or that you have troubles with or
that you would like to have a deeper
understanding about and so we'll stay on
openings and I'll turn it over to
yourselves like which openings are any
but any of you having trouble with right
well one of them I'll just make it a
little bit more myself one of the one of
the moves that was really annoying for
me is when my opponent played d4 and I
was black I was playing Queens gambit
accepted and seriously my record was
great with the Queens gambit accepted so
a lot of my opponents were tricking me
or attempting to trick me they would
play Knight f3 on their first move
I was playing d5 hoping to get into my
Queens gambit accepted routine so what
would happen my problem is I really
wanted to play Queens gambit accepted
but my opponents would be very tricky in
this position they wouldn't play III
yardies or they wouldn't play III which
would allow me to get into my comfort
zone which was this I so this is the
kind of lettuce call it the tabia
position for the Queens gambit accepted
they wouldn't allow me to do this and
instead after c4 par me after takes they
would play Knight a3 so they would
recapture the pawn on c4 in a different
way and I was thinking that I was
equalizing here that I had some very
serious doubts after the move g3 I
actually think that this position is is
simply good for white
and I didn't do very well when my
opponents did this against me so I had a
problem with this particular move order
Knight f3 d5 yeah yeah I ninety cents a
bet what one of Ben's best efforts
Bishop e6 he took Ben took and the old
the old double attack routine was foiled
then been spotted the move beehive and
yes he won the game
so what happened in my particular case
is when my opponents would would try to
trick me with their move order of Knight
f3 cd5 c4
I learned to play this variation and
this was played I think in Alekhine irva
and back in the 1930s back in the day
and the main line for for for that time
this is what I learned as the main line
for white and for black and for some
reason this move or even Knight d5 or
very annoying and then after d3 they
would play Knight f6 Bishop e3 Queen
would go back we're not a hundred
percent sure where let's just choose a
square d6 for example and then either
with Bishop e2 or with d4 White got an
easy advantage
Black's development again as in that
harmonious as Queen on d6 is kind of
well blocking a bishop on f8 but I
discovered I pretty sure it wasn't my
discovery I discovered that in this
position I had a really really cool move
which basically put the kibosh on this
entire variation then is aware of the
move Knight h6 Knight age sex so that's
like a weird offside move but it starts
to make sense when Bishop e2 I play just
success as far as yes that was that's
the idea so the whole idea from blacks
point of view is to control the square
d4 let's go back for just one move so
imagine in this position Bishop e3 let's
put my queen not on the happiest square
but okay I go back to d8 so I'm not I'm
not I'm not encouraging 94 but really
now we start to see that the battle is
shaping up for the square d4 if d4 my
night is coming here if Bishop e2 my my
Bishop is coming on to this very nice
diagonal Bishop comes to g7 and I
actually just like blacks position I'm
not only comfortable I'm more than
comfortable so my opponents stop playing
that I'd like to share it so I would say
d3 night h6 Bishop
okay so what's the idea Sam
g6 let's just say Bishop III queen
backwards g4 g4 is new g4 Wow
so the idea is you just want to corral
my Knights on h3 and so then the idea is
that this Knight is a little loops I
don't want to go backwards I beg you
so after for example a move like a thigh
so you could chase me back it's not
exactly purgatory
yeah exactly d4 so it kind of looks a
little kings in the initial I'm not sure
if that's true or not but it's something
yes a very very good question seriously
that is I mean you know you play a move
like Knight h6 maybe you're going to get
punished and so Knight loops
Jesus where's my I pressed the wrong one
sorry
so Knight h6 is the top so how about
taking it new variation okay so before
you take it one one consideration that
comes to mind is you first kick the
Queen backwards so now you kick the
Queen backwards now you take it okay
so you get so you get blacks pawns
doubled and that's a key consideration
but as recompense I do have the two
bishops and when the bishop does come to
g7 it really controls this long diagonal
and it's my feeling was it was
more than adequate compensation it's
just a kind of a judgment call it will
take a lot of experience and practice to
prove it but often times and I get this
experience from the French defense I
sometimes play Knight h6 they take my
knight and it turns out that White's
missing his dark square bishop and he's
got this very big hole in the middle of
the board I'll have it out I had an
experience recently at the US Open so I
am in Vancouver Washington man and I'm
playing a low-rated player in the early
parts of the tournament maybe it was
Game one maybe it was Game two I am not
too sure but in a sense my rating gap
was so great I mean if I don't win this
game yeah I think I they take away 200
rating points right yeah about that may
be closer to expert yeah but my opponent
played efore I would normally playing
Grandmaster play caro-kann or something
main line I'd like also the timing off
variation as Black Knight f3 d6 d4 CD
I've done a lot of work on this
variation for black and essentially
today it's very very topical you see a
lot of Grandmaster games playing with
the so-called Rio variation yeah so this
position happens to be a very very
topical position amongst top
grandmasters and you see players
actually playing even both sides of it
so I played the move knight c6 and I
absolutely despise this fashion at all
I mean it just curls my blood so my
opponent played a move that I found very
annoying point Knight be fun
no it's not specialty coffee yet so of
course he wants to occupy D services
he's discouraging nigt seven a goal and
one I mean talk about own goal right
Knight G so I played right now if I get
this position guess what we're right
group right in the mainline sveshnikov
and I don't play this variation as black
I despise the position for both color I
think I don't want anything to do with
this position so I played what I thought
was a very natural move in this position
after the move Knight b5 yep I play d6
so I of course in thinking that if it's
my turn I'm going to refute the move
Knight be fine I'm just going to play a
six and drive the night away my opponent
played Bishop ef4 and I got the very
strange impression that I've been
outfoxed in the opening that darn guy I
mean because if I play e5 let's say
Bishop e3 I could play a kind of a
Knight f6 but it's looking kind of
session Acuff light to me even though
maybe I have a good version maybe I do
maybe I don't I'm not sure but never oh
I play special coffee yes oh yes oh yes
I could would weigh about two years ago
I was in a tournament in Holland an open
tournament and I had played a massive
number of junior players man was I
feeling old you know like these guys
were just kids or Sam's age for crying
out loud and in the last round for first
place
I played sveshnikov and I felt like the
youngster
I would like a great feeling happy to
see of Jenny I was like welcome welcome
welcome
so I didn't want to do this so I so
instead of the movie 5 I played 95 and
here I'm happy to say my opponent went
into what we could call the tank meaning
deep thought ok so the move 95 is a
basically an in-your-face kind of move
the first thing we must note is that
Queen d4 is a fail this simply failed
because of Ben's move Queen a5 check and
this time the double attack works the
double attack works black picks back his
Bishop on e5 yep
so that's nice so the first thing we
realize is Queen d4 is not the right
move 94 so Queen D so essentially in
this position what I'm saying to white
is you went Knight G 1 to F 3 to d4 to
b5 you tracked all the way across the
board
you provoke my Knight to e5 which is
actually a wonderful square thank you
very much for for doing that and if you
allow me I'm going to play the move a 7
a 6 picking up a crucial tempo and as my
opponent was thinking thinking thinking
I realized that there was one and only
one move in this position that gives
white any advantage can you guess what
it might be ok
after C 4 you're a little bit worse a
little bit just a little bit so I will
go a 6
this is important do you want to go
night b-52d four or 2c3 yes what moment
after 95 Butte Bishop III so if I play a
six and you go backwards then
essentially what I'm saying is that in
this particular variation of the
Sicilian White has provoked my Knight to
e5 where I'm saying I'm thanking you
that's actually a good square for my
knight and I'm getting a six with tempo
so what Sam is trying to say is that
with this move he's trying to set up a
mirach see buying so Sam after a six
where would you like to go with an item
B yes exactly that was the question
where did you want to go to d4 or c3 so
now we have a yeah like correct you lose
a temple a yes because not only does it
matter in fact oops I keep touching them
a favorite line of Spassky was to play a
hedgehog where he went ninety eight to
d7 to e5 to g6 voluntarily and he got
positions that were very good for black
to Tempe behind to Tempe behind so in
this case I'm very very pleased to have
the black position so after Knight e5 my
opponent goes into a deep think and he
plays the wrong move let me just show
you what my opponent played so we can
understand for a moment what needs to be
avoided
I played a six again ninety four he's in
some main variations a tempo behind and
the bishops misplaced on f4 so he took
took took took castles check Bishop d7
ninety six and all of these moves were
played after his long thing relatively
quickly
my opponent made a strange move here
what move did my opponent make let's say
he may move Bishop e2 that's not so
strange
Bishop c6 now he made a strange flow
sorry now he put Bishop to d3 and after
g5 I wanted it in a very easy way my I'm
just going to make some bad moves for
him so you can see how I want it I did a
very strange thing I want it by doubling
on the H file it was high yeah yeah yeah
yellow is he thank you so it was like
okay so what happened in this particular
position so once we got here I was
already feeling very good
I would let's say he didn't play the
move Bishop e2 let's say he played the
move f3 or no Bishop e2 was fine I
apologize Bishop e2 was fine Bishop e2
Bishop c6 f3
ok so here we're going to just look at
the variation 2 position from the point
of view of the pawn structure black
obviously has five pawns on the center
to the king side versus four White has a
majority on the Queen side so it's clear
that my play which is very very simple
and robust is I want to use my majority
so let's say I play g5 let's just say he
doubles rooks on the open file which is
what all of the books basically say we
should be doing well if you notice all
of the business squares oops all of the
business squares meaning d6 the d6
square the d7 square and the d8 square
covered you've got the D file and
nothing else going for it
your real problem is that your majority
a - B - C - you're not using it so black
had a very easy game I'm going to play G
for rook on a a - g8 and White's ending
up on the defensive so this main line
main variation and most natural move
actually ends up being a situation that
is bad for white so Knight c3 bad move a
six takes takes everything happened and
black ended up with the initiative or
let's just simply say not just the
initiative but a superior position so
back to this position gentlemen ladies
what should white play what should white
play there's one and only one move in
this position obviously if I can play a
six the knight f6 and Queen c7 I have a
very very comfortable position Queen d4
is fails to a six capture the night
that's transposes that transposes into
the game not good for blood not good for
white to capture the knight and trade
queen as it turns out uncle say uncle
do I hear Uncle Sam you have a
suggestion for black for white perhaps a
for okay a force reasonable move but it
really doesn't disturb me from getting a
comfortable Sicilian position but by the
way the move Bishop Knight b5 and Bishop
f4 very well known I'm sure it was well
known even before Petrosyan Fisher from
their candidates match of 1971 where
Bobby Bobby
Petrosyan was black and in this moment
Petrosyan played to move e5 Bobby played
Bishop III Petrosyan played Knight g5
Bobby played Bishop g5 Bobby won a much
worse position he essentially
essentially went to do a special knack
off a tempo behind and won but that's
not good
it's a silly idea from Bobby yeah so uh
sorry Knight e5 so shall I show
ninety-two very nice variation but again
after a six night here night here
essentially black is again in a very
comfortable Sicilian position where he
several Tempe up and Lex King is very
solid
his center is very solid he's got ideas
like b5b for so again I would find it
more comfortable for me to play the
black position in that case no that's
just a bishop takes d6 so the move that
I discovered at the board which is very
very counterintuitive and it's the only
move for white to have an advantage is
this one that's it that's the only move
everything else correct everything else
is
yes so absolutely the same position as
we saw before with one small difference
the Knights on a three and not on c3 on
c3 White's not using his majority on a
three white is so for example if black
played a move like b7 b5 now we can talk
about something here that's very very
important in chess that happens very
very often one of the things that we've
got to do is we've got to use our
Trump's right so from blacks point of
view my trumps are the majority over
here from whites point of view his
majority as his Trump's are the majority
over there now when I play the move b5
am I playing to my Trump no certainly
not a move like g5 place to my Trump but
here there's a problem the desirable g5
fails miserably to Knight c4 now my pawn
on e5 is hanging there are ideas that
wipe me play with his night to b6 so
with his night on a3 Sam said how about
the move b5 now this changes a great
deal over the game first of all one
thing that white could do is play the
move c4 and let's say we get a position
like this now here we see a crucial
difference white already has a passed
pawn maybe we like blacks position maybe
we like White's position that's
debatable
but another problem with the move b5 is
let's say white place c3 now essentially
with the move b5 I've created a bit of a
weakness here I've created a weak poops
that wasn't what I wanted to do the pawn
on a6 the pawn on d5
that wasn't what I wanted to do that is
vulnerable because in my eyes let's say
I play move like g5 variation on that
side play move like Bishop b2 let's say
play move like g4 night here and I'm not
exactly sure maybe we'll just throw
these moves in just to given a taste of
what is coming so let's say I play the
move rook here and I don't know I mean
in the game what I did was so very easy
that it was almost to to smooth a
victory now we almost got a position
like this in the game I actually kept my
pawn back on h7 because I showed you I
doubled on the H file but here again Y
kid is a chance to use his majority with
is night on c2 oops that wasn't the move
I wanted I want to play the move a4 and
we start seeing right away that there
are counter chances for white let me try
to show one variation just as an
exceptional there was some variation I
was looking that went like this like
this kind of a thing and you can see
something has gone very wrong for her
for her for black he sacrificed
exchanged but he's facing moves like 98
and 95 so white is winning so this was I
mean just for your information and again
for those of you who do play E for this
was a lesson for me that you know when
you're faced a new idea new new
situation you have to start thinking
outside of the box and start coming up
with something creative because the move
might be 1 2 a 3 would simply it
shouldn't be first second third fourth
fifth six on your list of candidate
it moves but it was the only move to
keep any edge for white yeah well
exactly and in the game as I said in the
game the strangest thing was that the
night was actually which would Knight c3
open me I certainly can let me just go
back for UPS yet 95 night a3 a6 yes yes
Knight c4 oops that's not Knight c4 it's
not even close okay Knight c4 whoa that
move new variation had not occurred to
me either before or after the game okay
so the idea is twofold
White has Knight b6 ideas attacking
bishop and other ideas Knight e5 okay so
let's take a look at what I can do about
both so in one case let's say I take
white would play this move I would play
this rook d7 King here Bishop b5 and I
don't think black is long for this world
this is not a happy situation first of
all I think white can just wipe black
out
how does white what's been what's the
killer move here yeah I did what I mean
the position is set the table is
beautifully set for checkmate I'm just
having a hard time omen I don't think
black this is very good for black and
not give the rock right Bishop e5 just
looks so so weak so we could probably
reject army
Knight c4 looks great just a second so
let's reject 8x b5 and well let's see it
again just because I love being contrary
and what did you do
Knight b6 oh so I'll play here meet
Bishop takes be fun
Knight d7 is that that looks Knight
takes D seven that look that is being
timid okay so we've got we've got some
very key supporters for whites mites
move just a second pom-poms 94 is a cool
move I and again I didn't consider it
before after during how about just a
funny move for a moment Knight f6 Knight
b6 does it transpose I was trying to do
something
I was trying to try I was hoping that in
case you took my rook not forced I was
hoping that I I would be able to trap
the knight or maybe you re you took I
could even take no no no cancel that is
not a good move I will have to stop rook
d7 that yes it's weird it has the
feeling right the feeling should be in
our fingertips and we should recognize
that something went wrong so let's just
see what did I did what sorry sorry say
it again
Bishop C Knight f6 yes
Knight takes e5 now that is a cotton a
kind of a transposition into and you got
if I I sucked you before I was sucking
you to b6 and now you want a pond looks
looks really good for white so 8x b5
Knight takes e5 so night c4 not Knight
d6 and it looks like very good intention
I know it's like you know I know right
bit pleases sorry King Issa okay is it
and then suddenly the night okay but
after the move King e7 oops
solid oops
I'm telling you baby you are in the you
you are you're in the wrong battle yes
true
and I I miss yeah yeah yeah yeah
overwrite solid yes you gotta get your
pieces out of the center okay yeah bad
night now your nights aren't is it yeah
so that that's a good that's a good sign
I didn't realize that my position was so
drastic
correct okay new new main line and all
that way
one of the classic classic moments in
our broadcast day which is it's just
really unforgettable as 12 year old
Jeffrey came out and you know was very
politely showing is is it games and Ben
said it's in the way you know I just
look playing I I bet he goes back back
back back tuck tuck this look I must say
at first sight and second sight and
third sight and forth sight it sure
looks good for for white here
it sure does I mean I want it somehow
trap the Knights but not only they
dancing they're dancing and prancing and
winning material it's true so
so just a second I wonder if you have a
move this naughty six after night well
probably I might own one two a three
maybe I should play something silly like
Knight f6 because again my opponent
didn't lay this his his move was Knight
c3 and well maybe still I don't think
Knight c4 here whoa
that is interesting
man that's Oh and this is what I do by
the way when I you know encounter
openings that I am have trouble with you
know I literally try to dig deep and and
analyze these moves
so Knight c4 here yeah
yes I do hey Queen e2 Sam
checkmate Hey no you're not worried
about me you didn't even just see the
check okay so I'll probably go for this
c3 and let's get rid of that guy finally
it's I just want to get rid of that
night on b5 because it's bothering yes
that's legal and you can get my queen
around a little bit but I don't think of
the end yes indeed everybody it's a
free-for-all but uh
it looks like mate let's try it again
because it works so well last time
that's not checkmate thank our guests
would be for ooh you pull ahead Caro
honest if you watch every second run now
this might be big yeah this this might
be made here I would start calling
emergency services Queen t4 is a fine
move I let's just toss it avoiding
resignation and let's say should what
should white take this night I was
thinking this this this this he was
taking our bit maybe here isn't that an
amazing move and I agree that night c4
is really quite something for white it
wasn't in my mind but what was in my
mind is oh my gosh how does white get an
advantage night a3 and working out those
variations openings for me are really
really wonderful challenges and that's
the way I look at them as challenges